how do you keep the economy growing and
families fed when the price of almost
everything is rising faster than for a
generation
this cambridgeshire family farm is
grappling with the question
they grow potatoes for their own brand
crisps
but fertilizer has doubled in cost
sunflower oil they're fried in meanwhile
has risen even more these will have been
harvested anywhere between sort of
august and and november or they laid off
late october last year
just one consequence of the war in
ukraine being felt at home
uh 80
of the sunflower oil which is what we
were always using and we still are at
the moment but we'll have to move to uh
rapeseed oil but 80
comes from ukraine and russia
and with nothing coming out at the
moment it's it's not even a question of
how much it costs in this country it is
simply unobtainable
consumer price inflation reached a
30-year high of 7 in march up from just
0.7 a year ago that's more than three
times the bank of england's 2 target and
the bank says it could reach 10 percent
later in the year
the price of everything involved in this
process from growing the potatoes to the
oil they're fried in has gone up because
the war in ukraine has accelerated
inflation that was already happening
commodities are more expensive raw
materials are more expensive crucially
fuel and energy are more expensive and
that affects the price of almost
everything from the field to the factory
and eventually to the high street and
the bad news is it's going to get worse
[Music]
they're feeling the fuel pinch at
manchester's new smithfield market where
mariella sells fish to wholesalers and
the public
prices we are incurring at the moment it
is torturous having to why is everything
going on why is that because we have to
because everything has gone up by at
least 25 30 percent the cost of our
deliveries our diesel bill is up um 1500
a month just the increase in diesel
rising costs on the farm will eventually
find their way to the fork
and employers like grind a chain of nine
coffee and cocktail sites across london
also face higher wages and paying more
national insurance on top of everything
else
huge inflation with pressure on
everything you know from
labor when labor costs went up five
percent last week with the with the
april the first changes commodity coffee
price which is related to the coffee we
buy is two and a half times higher than
it was
energy bills 50 up for us you know some
of the sites are now double digits a
month in terms of their you know their
electricity bill for those sites the
economy hasn't faced a challenge like
this for decades squeezed between rising
prices and falling real incomes
businesses and consumers will have
little room for maneuver
paul kelso sky news